my experience with Bill Cosby through
both performing at noon in Atlantic City
at some casino it was in the middle of
the afternoon and the casino managers
was like mr. Cosby wants you to meet him
and he's up in his hotel room I was like
I'm not going up to his hotel room alone
and so I made three guys come with me
now I know yeah of course he was trying
to roofie me I mean clearly that's the
only who else called you up to their
hotel room in the middle of the
afternoon and then was kind of pissed
that I had three guys with me I was like
who are these guys what are they doing
here I'm like who are you doing here
so here's the thing about Chelsea and
probably one of the reasons she's BFFs
with Jennifer Sandra and Rhys she is
smart wicked funny and beyond brutally
honest now there were some rumors that
you were kind of into Orlando Bloom no
that's but that's all job loli do you
you work in this industry Orlando and I
are friends we have never ever once
hooked up ever and believe me he's
hooked up with a lot of people in the
past you've often made fun of the
Kardashians audiences I cannot get
enough of this half hour minion army of
asses you all Chloe shows up in the
series our society is so caught up on
like getting validation weirdo who's
family back into Chloe has a great sense
of humor I'm doing Chloe's show too I
mean Chloe's my friend she's cool you
know we just have it under she knows
she's cool enough to get it I mean I see
those girls all the time so they either
have to get over it or not I mean I've
run into like him at our friend's house
and you know sometimes I run it on my
phone no here she is and then I have to
be like hey Kim after all the stuff I've
said but you know what I just have to
you just have to stand up and take it
and go listen I know that I said stuff
and you know
you